fred when do you realize you have to
have george sexually
the first time we uh
consummated our relationship sexually
was at the end of the los angeles
marathon on march 5th
1986 wow
impressive impressions i remember it
are you working on a book or something
because that's a tremendous recall
what do you remember george he doesn't
remember this well no
i had uh a uh adr additional
dialogue recording for a miami vice
that i did but before that we were kind
of playing around
uh my town house and um
we happened to be in the bedroom and one
thing led to another and
we started wrestling and
and that was the first time and
so i i i think that was the best dubbing
job i did
you mean the wrestling though it's it's
it's it's an odd thing to me
that every session of lovemaking begins
with wrestling and it's almost
i like to squeeze i like to feel i let's
you know
get a little nervous isn't it brad were
you brad were you like uh what's with
this [ __ ] guy with the wrestling
i mean i mean you're probably
want let's make love not war i mean it's
funny i
remember the first time it was it was in
his bed
on the third floor of this town house
and i remember the springs were
squeaking
and i remember it's very noisy like
squeak squeak squeak
i remember being on the floor
were you doing the same thing yeah maybe
you guys weren't in the same room
are you sure you're not remembering
somebody else maybe that was somebody
else
was he was george the first man that you
were in love with brad
or were there others no because i wasn't
you know george and i are an
older couple i was in my early 30s
george was in his late 40s so we'd had
relationships breakups the normal
dating life before we found each other
were you nervous that george was this
big star from star trek and everything
did you say oh my god look what i'm
taking on with this guy i mean you know
you know
well i mean i don't mean to be
self-serving but truthfully he was just
that guy from star trek to me because i
lived in los angeles
i worked in the hollywood area and he
was just another he was another
unemployed actor
[Music]
well listen the two of you are amazing
you are
the couple of all couples i feel you are
an inspiration
not only to the gay community but to the
community at large